hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Gotham episode 12 video I
think I almost had more fun with the
characters like with the characters
interacting than I did with the actual
villain usually the episode is all about
them defeating whatever villain is but
sometimes you have more fun with certain
character interactions so if you haven't
seen any of my previous videos this past
week I'm changing the way I do my review
videos just a little bit so I'm gonna do
my top 5 moments then I'll do Easter
eggs and then I'll do top 5 thumbs down
instead of just giving a simple rating
so here we go careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet
starting with top five moments number
five Peter Scolari is Commissioner Loeb
so if you didn't see him Commissioner
Loeb is the Commissioner from the Dark
Knight trilogy he's this guy right here
he appeared for the first time in Batman
number 404 as part of the Batman year
one story line after he died eventually
his successor was Jack Grogan then after
that is when Gordon became commissioner
so there was actually one Commissioner
in line between him and Loeb I'm a big
fan of Peter Scolari as an actor I think
he brings a nice energy to the show I
really like the way he and Gordon bounce
off of each other in this I don't know
how many episodes he's gonna be in but
I'm betting that he's gonna show up
again before the end of the season you
don't cast a really notable character
actor like that and then just never
bringing them back if you guys get HBO
you might remember him as lena Dunham's
father on girls did anyone else feel
like they heard him speak in batman
voice when he said where do you get that
rebellious fire it's like you see the
gloomy clouds that are always in the
Gotham horizon make the Batman symbol
for just a second
scolari also played Gunther Hardwick aka
the shark on the animated series so he
has been in the Batman universe before
Imoh is on the lookout to see if guest
actors have starred in some other Batman
production before everybody in Hollywood
wants to play a Batman character at some
point number four
Falcone's flashback I was really happy
to see Falcone get his together in
this episode based on the way the actors
played it it's it's really bit hard to
tell how much he knows about what's
going on around him like all these
secret plots they kind of answered some
of those questions I wasn't super
satisfied but at least now they've drawn
a line in the sand lately the show has
taken a little bit more time to focus on
other characters so a lot of my
complaints against Falcone's character
are just that they haven't had time to
service him on-screen so I have to take
a lot of the jumps in his character on
faith like his relationship with Liza
for instance I'm pretty dissatisfied
with the way that
played out but I do love that he
strangled her to death I just think it's
so hilarious just because you get this
weird thing where it's like maybe he's
thinking he's strangling his mother in
his mind like if he has some weird
Norman Bates psycho thing going on I
don't think that's part of the character
but I wouldn't be surprised if I see
something like that on tumblr and some
chipset let me know if you agree though
do you think it's in the subtext if he's
so hung up on his mother like he won't
stop talking about his mother clearly
obsessed with her and he feels Liza
embodies his mother and he kills Liza
does that also mean that he's killing
his mother is crazy as that would be I
you know I don't think it's in the
literal interpretation but I do think
it's funny just to consider that on the
side moving on to number three though
the Riddler starts leaving elaborate
clues behind as a way to communicate
with Miss Kringle I feel like we're
gonna start seeing more and more of this
as we get into season two and by the way
Gotham has been renewed for season two I
didn't say that at the top of the video
it got a full order for season two so
we'll see plenty more of nygma leaving
weird clues for people I can't I can't
wait of all the characters in this
episode I would say like their scenes
the krinkle Riddler scenes probably my
favorite next to the Gordon Thompkins
scenes that was like what I said at the
beginning of the video you know
sometimes the way characters interact
like they're funny interactions are more
rewarding for viewers than like the big
twist like the big villain reveals I
totally love Chris Heyerdahl he's an
amazing character actor but I feel like
his villain wasn't quite as much fun as
some of the characters in this episode I
was a little surprised that he didn't
get pissed when she gave him the cupcake
back but then later in the episode they
paid it off a little and he very much
had that I'm sick of this look on
his face I'm interested to see where
they leave his character at the end of
this season what they're teasing is is
that he's just gonna slowly break down
mentally then he'll start committing
crimes leaving elaborate clues that way
as a way to get attention from people to
make people notice him moving on to
number two the electrocutioner z' attack
on the police department this is like
the big action set piece of the episode
visually it looked amazing like I love
the way they pulled it off even though
Gordon's take down to the
electrocutioner it seems a little too
easy
I get what they were going for they
wanted to show that Gordon is every bit
as clever if not more so than the super
villain but it feels like there was a
missing music cue like it's supposed to
be a bigger payoff like in the dark
night whenever Batman takes down the
Joker's 18-wheeler you get that moment
of silence and then all of a sudden just
this huge takedown
it felt like this was meant to be a
little bit like that at least in spirit
but it just didn't come off that way but
still the way they filmed the light show
the way they pull that off great great
action set piece and my number one
moment from the episode any scene with
Morena Baccarin and Ben McKenzie but
doctor Lee Thompkins
Gordon forever I feel like one of the
best moves this show has made in the
back half of the season is bring Morena
Baccarin on the show she makes any scene
that much more fun I feel like a lot of
it's in the conception of her character
like the way the writers use her in the
story but just as an actress she's so
much fun
Gotham is a show totally is is really
depressing I mean this is all about
Batman villains in the city going to
so she is like the sugar poured on
top just to make things like a little
bit sweeter like a little bit easier to
take in that scene that they left on
like obviously they hooked up in the
bathroom I totally love that she walked
into the men's room to see Gordon she
very clearly knew he was going to be
naked in there so she was coming in to
do some shenanigans with him the cop
coming in to interrupt with the crime
obviously throws a big wet blanket on
everything but I think it just shows
that crime in Gotham is always going to
haunt Gordon's relationships like you
know it won't him well between those
characters because obviously Barbara
Gordon has to come at some point and
that means that he has to get married to
Barbara Kean something has to happen to
her either way all of Gordon's
relationships end up broken he ends up
alone although he eventually does get
his daughter Barbara there are so many
things I can say about Morena Baccarin
so I'll try and limit myself from week
to week as she shows up the sheer fact
that she had like that take-charge
attitude of like okay I really like this
Gordon person so I'm going to pursue him
by going into the bathroom normally
that's something you see a male
character do like they would pursue a
female character into the bathroom so I
just like the way they're framing Leslie
Thompkins she's very smart she knows
what she wants she goes after it she's
not afraid I feel like they just have so
much more chemistry on-screen than he
and Barbara did so as much time as they
can keep Barbara and Gordon apart I am
all for it I don't know how long Morena
Baccarin is gonna stay on the show
hopefully she sticks around for season
two so fingers crossed on that so here's
my big question for you guys this is
actually a little bit different so do
you like the character interactions more
or do you like the big action set-pieces
on Gotham just on Gotham specifically I
really feel like what goes on between
the characters like the way their
relationships develop is always more
interesting than the big villain twists
they just
it's more fun to watch them evolve and
watch their relationships change whether
they be working relationships or sexual
relationships or something else so
moving on to Easter eggs so there are a
couple really big ones that I saw in the
episode but if you caught any other
minor ones just add them in the comments
so first off was Commissioner Loeb I
think I already mentioned the comic book
that he debuted in and who he was in the
comics a lot of fun can't wait to see
Peter Scolari come back the next big one
I saw was the sorceress in dr. Thompkins
Wing she's really popular all I could
think was Morgan la Fey there's not that
many sources in the Batman universe and
she just happens to be one of the
biggest ones and then of course the
Riddler leaving his elaborate clues
behind I feel like he leaves clues
behind as a way to communicate with
people like he's not a people person as
much as he seems like he is when he
wants to tell someone something he just
leaves them a clue it'd be like if he
wanted to talk to someone or tell them
something really difficult he would send
them a link to your tumblr post so as
much fun as the episode was there were a
few thumbs down I had so let's see
number one I would say yeah the Falcone
lies a relationship I feel like they
just they haven't spent enough time on
screen developing that we did see a lot
of them before the episode went on break
I mean we have gotten scenes with them
together but it is I found it a little
ridiculous that he had trouble buying
the Penguins confession that she was on
the take the whole time I mean if he's
this smart he probably would have
figured that out on his own already next
thumbs down so Gordon taking down the
electrocutioner just seemed a little too
easy also a thumbs down penguin spitting
gibberish at Maroni trying to convince
him he's telling the truth about
visiting his mother it kind of looked
like he was getting ready to wet his
pants like he was looking for the
bathroom
I feel like he got something of a
criminal Redemption at the end of this
episode where he got to say goodbye to
fish Mooney so to speak but when he
starts like flipping out like trying to
explain something to someone else like
he gets a little too crazy like a little
too hyperactive and then my last thumbs
down was just the car ad that they did
so what they're doing is this three week
behind the scenes think three or maybe
four week behind the scenes thing it's
really a car ad so Robin Lord Taylor is
doing like this car integration where
it's a for dad for like a Ford hybrid
but he goes behind the scenes of Gotham
it shows his behind the scenes stuff I
totally love them trying to do stuff
like that I love creative integrations
arrow did it with blood rush in season
two but I feel like if they were gonna
do a car ad it would have been more fun
for them to do like a version of the
Jaguar ad from last year with Tom
and the other big villain actors just
being funny on screen like you had
Victor Zsasz and the other Gotham
villains driving around town and the
Ford just saying why it was so much fun
to be a villain
owning a Ford although I guess maybe
that's not the message that Ford wanted
to convey Ford hybrid the number one
choice for Batman villains actually if
they'd have had poison ivy they could
have played the zero emissions angle
that would have been even better on all
really fun episode though I loved Morena
Baccarin always want to see more of her
on the show so hopefully more Leslie
Thompkins in related news arrow and the
flash are coming back this week and I'm
going on a special podcast the CW fan
talk that's on Wednesday at 4 p.m.
Pacific time I'll be posting my flash
video before that so I'll just I'll
remind everyone about that whenever I
post my flash review be sure to
subscribe to get that video I'm really
excited it's gonna be very rogue heavy
in the back half of the season so you're
gonna need a lot of new rows and arrow
comes back on Wednesday so they'll just
be dealing with the aftermath of
Oliver's supposed to death even though I
don't think that he's dead while you
guys wait for all that stuff to come
back you can click here to catch up on
air on the flash and you can click here
for all my Gotham videos thank you so
much for watching so let's all high-five
I'll see you tomorrow
you